what I'm going to do is I'm going to
just Define a recursive formula for us
and then we're going to prove an
explicit formula but I'm not going to
give it to you I want to see if we can
actually work out what is the explicit
formula and then we can try and prove it
okay so here's example one okay let's
suppose there's some sequence of numbers
A1 A2 A3 just like this is like t n f n
so this is going to be a n we'll start
off with one and then to get to the next
term in the sequence what we do is
each term is going to be equal to we'll
double the previous term so double
the previous term
and then we'll add one
double the previous term and then add
one
so
normally in the syllabus they would then
hand you an explicit formula and then
they'd say prove okay that would
normally be the next step okay
and often this is the case for example
when you do integration there are some
integrals where it's like okay you're
gonna have to substitute something in in
extension one they'll tell you here's
the substitution you should use but in
extension two they're like no top lock
you work it out okay now I actually want
us to work this out because it's totally
doable and actually it's a very
important thing to do mathematically so
how would we go about working out like
having a guess what the explicit formula
might be well
what are you any suggestions
yeah let's just let's just have a go
right and see what we get so we already
know what A1 is let's go ahead and work
out A2 I reckon you guys could do it in
your heads and then we can just write
down the answer we said we doubled the
previous one which gives us two and then
we add one so that tells us A2 will be
three
okay can we go another step what's the
next one
A3 yeah I'm going to double which gets
me to six add one seven just for good
measure let's go one more A4 double 14
and then you add one okay now let's have
a look
tell me what you notice about each of
these
one three seven
fifteen
they're all like numbers that's good
which should make sense because we got
from doubling which would give you an
even and then you add one which makes
you odd okay very good
yeah
the three which is the next odd and then
it goes to the second odd after three oh
yes
like five is hiding in there as a nod
number and then uh 9 11 and 13 are sort
of hiding in there and then we go to the
next one that's right and by the way if
we went again
you'd have how you'd skip over five of
them wouldn't you okay now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to do one more
thing to see if because again we're
doubling right
what happens if I add one
to each of the terms that we've got here
in this case I'd get two
in this case I'd get four and then eight
and then 16. what do you notice what's
special about these numbers
these real pals are two right and you
can guess the next one would be 32 but
then you'd be one less which would be 31
and you can actually just check right I
could take this double that would you
give me the 30 and then add one 31 which
is kind of what we expected right so
here is my hypothesis right I'm going to
suggest that there is an explicit
formula for this off the basis of all
these I'm going to suggest that
and I'm actually even going to write
hypothesis because I don't actually know
that this is the case right this is one
of the big differences between
mathematics and science in science if
you've got a bunch of examples and four
is not enough right you need 400 or 4
million right but once something happens
enough times repeated observation you're
like yeah this is this is just what
happens right but in maths that's not
enough you actually have to prove it
using logic even if I went a million
right and up to a million it's like it's
always a power of two minus one that
still wouldn't be a mathematical proof
right so what I'm going to do is suggest
and then work out a way to prove this
that the anth
a number right is going to be well how
do I express it
2 to the power of n and then it's one
less is that okay because um let's just
check here for example 2 to the 4 is 16
take away one two cubed is eight take
away one so it's looking good let's see
if this works okay now at this point
right I'm actually at where every
mathematical induction problem starts
right I've got a thing to prove I've got
some things here that I can use as logic
right and what's actually going to ensue
is going to feel I hope a lot like an
extension one proof by induction do you
guys know there's three steps right
for every proof by induction can you
tell me what they are before we start
um n equals one yeah fantastic so what
we do is we look at the the base case
the first place that it works so often
this is kind of a test right it's like
oh let's just see if this thing works at
all before we get going right what's the
second thing okay so yeah what's the
word yeah I need a verb right so I'm
going to assume I'm actually going to
say this hypothesis let's just assume it
does work for some particular value
right
um and then what I then have to do this
is where the work comes in it's the the
prove step right I mean the whole thing
is actually a proof but this is the one
where you're doing algebra or geometry
right um this is the one where the work
tends to be most of this happens quite
automatically okay a way that I often
think about it is that like you said
this is tends to be n equals one however
I will point out one of the differences
between extension 2 induction proofs
versus extension one extension one
always begins with n equals one but in
extension two we're like maybe what if
we don't at one maybe we started zero
maybe we started four you can start any
way you like the process the logic of it
will still actually be the same
um then you assume you assume it for
some arbitrary n and we call that okay
and then what's the proof what's the
particular end
the next one isn't it
right so I used to picture like a chain
of dominoes you're like can I prove that
if one will fall over the next one will
also fall over because then I can just
push over the whole lot by the way just
to mention right again difference
between extension one induction and
extension two induction this can be n
equals other stuff
this one here it's not always up by one
it can actually be up by two or up by
three so it could be n equals K plus
something else
again everything in extension two that's
related to extension one it's like let's
amp it up to the next level okay now
being this is our framework I actually
think
with a bit of a nudge we can do this
whole thing in just the same way that we
would do any other extension proof so
help me out what's our tests
what do you think is the worst the first
value equals one
okay yeah let's give it a go so what I
will do is I'm going to test this out
right I'm going to say the right hand
side
is equal to 2 to the power of one take
away one and you know because this is
something we have to we can't like skip
any steps here even though it's very
straightforward we actually want to make
sure it's two take away one so it's one
and that is indeed A1 right so I'm like
this is the left hand side so I can say
true
for an equivalent okay
so there's the test let's assume
true
four
and there's my n equals K right so
really all I'm doing is taking this my
hypothesis and I'm just going to
substitute everything in right so for n
equals K what does that give us
a k equals two the K minus one so fast
we're good
okay now the work begins so we have to
prove
prove
four
the next case over all right so I like
to write here like what am I actually
proving
um I.E just take that line there which
is a to the K but I'm going to
substitute in the K plus one
and then there's another K right there
so K plus one take one this is the theme
that I want to prove
okay now let me just pause for a moment
because if I just tell you what to do
next then I'm doing the thinking that
means I'm doing the learning right so
there's actually more than one place
that we could start here which would
totally work so I kind of want to throw
to you guys
or anyone in the room what might you
suggest like I know what I'm trying to
do now this is
this is my goal right where do you want
to go
and news
when you say initial one we're on the
board
this here yeah this one here okay so
this is uh where's my colors right
this is my recursive definition okay now
Ryan can you suggest for me
can you tell me why it was that your
brain went here first one
um
and if you put in a K plus one you'll
get rid of that fantastic yeah because
you'll get a K plus one take away one
and you're like oh that's just K and
I've already got an assumption for that
fantastic all right let's go ahead and
do that let me give you one up extra
reason like in addition to that which is
also correct
one of the reasons why I want to start
with this is because I know this to be
true right I can start with either
something I know as an equation which is
true my alternative which also could
work
is I start with one of these sides right
I can't write down this equation why not
I haven't proven it yet right so that's
going to be my final line not my first
one I can start with the left hand side
or the right hand side and then start
doing stuff to it much the same way that
we did here I started with the right
hand side and then I'm like ta-da I
ended up with the left hand side it's
true okay but if you've got something
which you already know is like done and
when you're doing
induction proofs that involved
inequalities that's another place where
it's like start with the thing you know
is true and then start interacting with
it that's often easier okay so let's go
ahead and write that I can say
a uh K plus 1 equals I'm just going to
the recursive definition
two a now just to be really clear
because this is a proof right I need to
make everything very explicit I'm going
to put in the K plus one right there
even though it's about to simplify very
very easily right plus one now because
this is beginning of my proof I've
actually got a state where I got this
from so I will say buy the recursive
definition
in some ways
um that makes it a bit like a geometry
proof right like every statement that
you have like this angle equals this
angle why like Give Me A Reason okay so
there we go I can then say as you
suggested Ryan that K plus one take away
one simplifies out
now what
okay Sean you can take from here
you've done this extension in extension
one we've used the recursive definition
what's the thing that I use that makes
proof by induction proof by induction
able to face standing up to me I don't
know if we're gonna use that there's
something this one here yeah okay so
let's have a look here right now I'll
admit this is one of the things that's a
little bit unusual about maths
particularly maths that we we give you
to solve
um in maths that we do we give yourself
as opposed to math problems out in the
real world right it tends to be that
you're like what have I not used yet
I've got to use it somewhere right the
real world sometimes doesn't play so
nicely right it's like you know what
sometimes the thing you need it's just
who knows where it is right have I have
I collected it have I recorded it I
don't even know in this case though in
math problems we give you the solve
they're quite well defined because we
don't want you just sitting there in the
exam just kind of scrolling I don't know
if this is solvable right I have not
used you might know this is sometimes
called the inductive
hypothesis
you don't need to know that phrase but
sometimes you'll see it in a textbook or
something like that or on the internet
right and it's called the inductive
hypothesis because I don't actually know
if it's true or not I'm just assuming
that it is okay now it's not a proof by
induction if you do not use that
assumption anywhere right if you didn't
need to use the Assumption you didn't
need to do induction right so I'm going
to use it and you can see there's the a
to the K right there so I can just do a
straight substitution so let's go ahead
and do that
so I've got 2 times this so I've got 2
to the K minus 1.
Plus 1. does that look okay straight
substitution again because I'm using
some prior logic I've got to say that I
am so I'm going to state that by
assumption
okay so far so good
now at this point I think we've done
pretty much all the hard work right can
you write the next line for me all right
um so two times two to the K we can
write that as to the K plus one perfect
so there's my index laws right I'll keep
expanding
um and then you can say
plus one plus two which becomes oh
careful hold on yeah watch out because
remember I do know where I'm going right
it's going to equal this
um and that actually Catches Us right
because if I if I had written let's just
write it down for now if I'd written
plus two plus one I'm going to get a
plus three out of this but I'm like oh
wait a second I'm supposed to land here
right so I know I've done something
wrong how can I fix this because it's
pretty close
it's a minus yeah very good so I'm gonna
fix that up minus two
plus one and that's going to give me
this and I'm pretty much home
minus one ta-da this was the uh this is
the result that I was required to prove
so I'll say as required
and um you guys might know
um at this point back when we did uh
extension two we used to have to write a
long paragraph here and explain like
um since it's truth and then you know
you'd have to complete all that but you
guys don't have to do that which is nice
there's lots of different ways to to
finish this off but I like to just say
by principle of
foreign
mathematical induction
statement is true that's it
so let's just rewind and make sure we
know what we've covered here right we
have been we start off with
uh a recursive definition right you will
normally be handed this hypothesis for
an explicit formula that doesn't require
you to look back and back and back it's
like you know what you could go straight
to the 15th one if you wanted without
knowing terms 1 through 14 but this
explicit formula that's the subject of
your proof by induction and then all the
rest of it feels like a pretty regular
proof by induction